[Music]
there's a reddit post to the stink bros
yeah you didn't see this no we meant to
play this on the live show the stink
bros was our our wrestling name yeah for
the video that we did
coding i'll do wrestling oh this is so
sick watch this
what can i do
isn't that insane it's the same
yeah how i think they just made the
characters in wwe or but you can get
that granular with it i think so yeah
streamers off the arms and everything
because that the ultimate warrior had
those
so that's like uh classic wrestling [__]
and even the suit is like
yeah like brett bret hart
heart yeah
which one of the heart brothers died
damn grim
i just remember it was on the front page
of the calgary sun i have a vivid memory
of this fell to his death during a
pay-per-view event yeah they were like
bringing him out on like a platform from
the ceiling and he fell off of it and
died
right when i was looking at pro
wrestlers and trying to get like
inspiration for like the look that we
were gonna have
i just looked all these dudes laughing
like
we are
runts compared to these like these
people's gene pool yeah
let's do skate like those dudes pulled
the womb open
massive meatballs yeah yeah huge they
came out literal meatballs yeah yeah
they were yeah they're no legs nothing
yeah just a ball of meat yes you just
want to throw this in the oven it's
going to congeal
macho man was his size at [__] three
years old what's the gist of this are
you reading it
yeah basically um
like you said he was repelled from the
rafters and he had done this stunt
before with a full harness and they
thought it made for bad television so
they did it with a lesser harness and
that's why he died
jeez you know that [__] that [__] like
they were just watching it
and then it went
and the stunt coordinator went oh
god
that's how that's how crazy intense
wrestling is though yeah
wrestling is is such a
man
especially early wrestling is so wild
west in terms of entertainment
i feel like
wrestling is one of the
like performance mediums that maybe like
maintain the [__] from early hollywood
like people dying on set i feel like
wrestling is one of the last to
kind of like
just come out of that era where it's
like no i'm gonna do the most dangerous
[__] possible yeah to promote this yeah
so
damn
well r.i.p
yeah calgary guy
look up uh macho man young i wonder what
he looked like at like 16. he just looks
nice as hell
skinny
working in a church
kind of nah
that second picture are you joking me
bro that dude was walking around like
that at 20 yeah
yeah this dude's always been huge holy
[__] he's a big guy you're a big guy
where's that from you're a big guy
damn it here we go again it's a quiz
it's a quiz for everyone here we go
again
you're a big guy you're a big guy
took it out of you
yeah you spent what were we laughing so
hard
[Music]
[Laughter]
everything let's just finish on this pug
noodles oh [__] yeah man
listen i'm a big fan of pugs they're my
favorite type of dog yet another round
of notes
no offense chilly if you're listening
and this old ass welcome back to yet
another round of no bones the game where
we find out if my 13 year old pug woke
up with bones and as a result we find
out what kind of day we're gonna have
now this could go either way noodle went
on a very sprightly walk last night so
he could be tired from that he could be
totally tired from that or he could
still be feeling jazzed from it
oh and he's feeling jazzed look at those
bones oh yeah lie down oh my gosh you
don't we don't need them to use them we
just need to know they're there
okay it's a bone stay on monday you guys
this is so exciting you know what to do
you've got to treat yourself today the
japanese fried chicken you were going to
order for lunch get the curry to dip it
in all those festive gourds buy them
that raise you deserve but haven't asked
for yet you totally deserve it ask for
it you got to treat yourself today good
morning everyone and
so what does the no bones look like
yeah that's what i wanna see
i wanna see a no bones day
good morning everyone and welcome back
to yet another round of no bones the
game where we find out yeah 13 year olds
no bones and in addition to find out
what kind of stuff you're doing this to
me i think it's pushing it to think
we'll get a third bone stay in a row
yeah
sure enough down he goes yo cut this off
okay
all right
can we head down to the convalescent
home covalescent home and why don't we
just play this game with somebody's
grandma yeah
what's up we're with here with martha
today we're gonna see if it's a bones or
no bones day
no
she's uh
[Music]
and it's a no bones day
it's no bones day so skull hits make
sure you get that sauce for the
for the no they just they lay out a
crash pad like a stunt crash pass so you
just hit that just
yeah oh no bones no bones so
you know we're still gonna have a good
day though right roll me over
roll me over comment how are you
self-caring today
she's just on the ground like
how are we all self-caring today
bones no bones
kyle said that home depot sells pug
bones do we have that
we don't
i just we tried to find as many in la as
we could and none of the home depots
have scroll up so we can see that [__]
damn that's scary
you know it's it's kind of you know it's
almost scarier to just buy that and just
put that on the porch like lazy
decoration for home that's always
off-putting yeah someone who just
doesn't put in enough effort you're like
um
is that a real dead why
why why
yo the stevie stinkbomb
yeah did everyone stock up oh they don't
know about that
the name of the dog
noodles
noodle
poor guy man
what a name for a guy every morning he's
like come on don't i'm just
i don't want to stand
i'm [__] 13.
how old is that in human years that's
[__] 101 he's like logan roy's age
yeah [__] off 92 is that what it is
i don't [__] know
put me down 96 something like that
[__] off get me on a plane to savoy
91 yeah oldest [__]
you